Once the iOS kernel has started,
it controls which user processes and
apps can be run to ensure that
all apps come from a known or
approved source and
have not been tampered with.
iOS requires that all executable code
be signed using an Apple
issued certificate.
More specifically, apps provided
with the device, such as Mail or
Safari, are already signed by Apple.
Third party apps must
also be validated and
signed using an Apple-issued
certificate.
This mandatory co-signing extends the
concept of chain of trust from the iOS
to the apps, and prevents third party
apps from loading unsigned code, or
using self modifying code.
A run time co-signature checks
of all executable memory pages
are being performed as the pages
are loaded to ensure that
our apps has not been modified since
it was installed or last updated.
This is done through a user-space
daemon and is enforced by the kernel.
In summary,
iOS enforces mandatory code signing and
identification to extend the chain
of trust from iOS to the apps.